Now the package has completed. Let's take a look at the packaged result.
So let's go to packaged and for me, I put it into result here.
So we see we have the executable, but we know we want to set things in the launch parameter.
So I'm going to go back to LRC demo and I'll just copy these two
batch files and I'll just put it in.
And I want to test things locally.
So I'll go to my sender batch file.
I'll do edit and here I will put my receiver IP to be my own local IPV4 address.
I'll copy and paste it here.
Save.
I'll close it.
Okay.
Now I'll put a sender.
I'll launch a sender, not full screen yet.
And now press Z to bring up the UI.
And now I will launch again as a receiver.
I'll put it on, let's do Z again and I'll put it on my right hand side.
So now if everything works correctly, my left hand window should be able to
communicate to my right hand window.
Okay.
That works.
I'm sending different colors.
I'm setting cubes on and off and the pink cube is following me.
Okay.
But because this is a one-way communication, I should not be able to.
Yeah.
So the receiver now is not able to send message back to the sender.
Okay.
Now for the sender, remember when you see V and B button to add, to do some
print strings on the receiver side.
Let's try it.
Now I press C.
The receiver is printing something and V is printing something else
and B is sending the boundo.
So that's all working correctly.
Make sure if we want to test two-way communication, we can only do it on two
different computers because we're doing it on the same computer that is going to
try to send message and do everyone sends out a message, the same instance
will also try to listen to that same, send out a message, which will create
some kind of a weird behavior.
So just remember that.
Okay.
In the next video, we'll go over how best to organize your Unreal
Engine project to maximize your ability to navigate it.